Naya Rivera arrested for domestic  battery  the former Glee star was arrested and  charged with misdemeanor domestic  battery on Saturday after an alleged  altercation with her husband Ryan Dorsey  a spokesperson for the Kanawha County  Sheriff's Office tells et that police  responded to a domestic violence  complaint at a home in Chesapeake West  Virginia and talked to Dorsey who  alleged that Rivera struck him in the  head and face the officer saw minor  injuries consistent with dorsey's  statement and according to the  spokesperson Dorsey also showed deputies  of video which supported his account of  the incident the 30 year old actress was  arraigned in court and then released on  bond her arrest comes just one month  after she filed to dismiss her divorce  from Dorsey Rivera filed for divorce in  November 2016 after two years of  marriage she endorsees share a  two-year-old son Josie